after a special medicine is introduced
into a petri dish full of bacteria the
number of bacteria remaining in the
decrease in the dish decreases rapidly
the relationship between the elapsed
time T in seconds and the number of
bacteria n of T in the petri dish is
modeled by the following function
alright complete the following sentence
about the half-life of the bacterial
culture the number of bacteria is halved
every blank seconds so T is being given
to us in seconds so let's let's think
about this a little bit let's think
about a little table here I'll draw a
little table here so if we have this is
T and this is n of T and I'll start with
a straightforward T at time equals zero
right when we start this whole thing if
this T is 0 then 1/2 to the 0 over 5
point 5 power that's just 1 after the
zero that's all going to be 1 and you're
just going to be left with one thousand
one thousand bacteria in the petri dish
now at what point do we get to multiply
by 1/2 at what point do we get to say
one thousand times 1/2 well in order to
say one thousand times 1/2 the exponent
here has to be one so at what time is
the exponent here going to be one
well the exponent here is going to be
one this whole exponents going to be one
when T is equal to five point five
seconds so T is five point five seconds
and likewise we wait another five point
five seconds so if we go to eleven
seconds then this is going to be one
thousand times eleven divided by five
point five is two so times 1/2 to the
second power so times 1/2 times 1/2 so
every five and a half seconds we will
essentially have half of the bacteria
that we had five and a half seconds ago
so the number of bacteria is halved
every five point five seconds and you
see it in the formula and the in the the
function definition right over there but
it's nice to reason it through and
really really digest why it makes sense
let's do a few more of these
the chemical the chemical element
einsteinium 253 naturally loses its mass
over time a sample of einsteinium 253
had an initial mass of 320 grams when we
measured it the relationship between the
elapsed time T in days in the mass M of
T and grams left in the sample is
modeled by the following function
complete the following sentence about
the rate of change in the mass sample
the sample loses eighty seven point five
percent of its mass every blank days so
this one instead of saying how much we
grew or shrunk by we're saying a percent
change so if you lose eighty if you lose
if you lose eighty seven point five
percent that means that you are left
with left with 12.5 percent 12.5 percent
which is the same thing is that you have
is the same way of saying that you have
0.125 percent of your mass so another
way of thinking about it is the the
sample has the sample is 0.125 of its
mass of its original mass or how long
does it take for the sample to be 0.125
of its mass and then we could do a
similar a similar idea you see the 0.125
right over here and so I could draw a
table if you like although I think you
might guess where this is going but let
me draw a little table here so T and M
of T when T is zero M of T is three
twenty and so at what point is T at what
time is M of T going to be 320 times
0.125 because this going from this to
this that is losing 87 point five
percent of your mass losing losing 87
please so let me just write it this way
so this is minus 87 point five percent
of the mass you've lost 0.875 to get to
0.125
so this you could just use 0.125 to the
first power so what what TD you have to
make this exponent equal one well T has
to be sixty one point four sixty one
point four and we're T is in days sixty
one point four days now you might be
tempted always just pattern match so
whatever is in the you know whatever's
in the denominator here but I really
encourage you to think about it because
that's the whole point of these problems
if you just our pattern matching these
well I don't know how helpful that's
going to be for you let's do one more of
these Howard started studying how the
number of branches on his tree grows
over time the relationship between the
elapsed time T in years since Howard
started studying the tree and the number
of its branches n of T is modeled by the
following function complete the
following sentence about the rate of
change in the number of branches
Howard's tree great gains four-fifths
more branches every black years so
gaining gaining 4/5 is equivalent to
multiplying multiplying by you're
gaining four-fifths of what you already
are you're not just getting you know the
number 4/5 you're getting 4/5 of what
you already are so that's the equivalent
of multiplying by one plus 4/5 or nine
fifths so gaining 4/5 is the same thing
as multiplying by nine fifths
if I'm five years old and if I gain four
fifths of my age I would gain five I've
gained four years to get to be nine
years old which means I've multiplied my
age by nine fifths so Howard's tree you
could say grows by a factor of nine
fifths every how many years well you
could see over here the common ratio is
nine fifths and so you're going to grow
by nine fifths every every time T is a
multiple of seven point three or as you
say every time T increases by seven
point three you're going to then this
exponent is going to increase by a whole
and so you could view that as
multiplying again by nine fifths so
Howard's tree gains four fifths more
branches every seven
three years